after months of negotiation with the
chinese government
members of the world health organization
team have arrived in wuhan
on a mission to trace the origins of
kobe 19.
we'll be looking at the in more detail
at the initial
cases the human cases that were detected
in december 19
looking at the market the famous wuhan
market and see
what happened there the team will also
investigate the theory that the virus
first came from an animal
and hopes to gain access to wuhan's
institute of virology
the trump administration has claimed
without evidence that the pandemic was
caused by a leak from this laboratory
u.s secretary of state mike pompeo has
accused the chinese government of a
cover-up
and on tuesday tweeted that the who was
corrupted by beijing
the u.n agency has denied the claims and
says its focus
is not about assigning blame but
uncovering facts to fight the pandemic
beijing has so far tightly controlled
any investigation into the outbreak's
origin
the who's mission comes as china is
struggling to contain an outbreak in the
country's north
with more than 700 cases discovered in a
week and the first coronavirus death
recorded in eight months
discovering the origins of kova 19 has
become highly politicized
many governments around the world have
been calling for an independent inquiry
but many are skeptical the chinese
government will provide full
access meanwhile the communist party has
been circulating its own narrative
about the outbreak's origins chinese
state media have been pushing reports
that the coronavirus was first
discovered in europe
in late 2019. beijing has been stoking
the theory
by pointing to traces of the virus on
imported frozen food
the who says this is highly speculative
but many residents in wuhan are
convinced
i welcome the who team to ohan to look
for the origin
because i don't believe china is where
it started
we were set up it didn't originate in
wuhan
not even in china health experts say
it's unlikely the who team will discover
the source of covert 19
anytime soon and additional missions may
be needed
it took them some 10 years to find the
origin of stars
how long would it take for kobe maybe
less time
because we have more experience but kobe
spreads more easily
and is more complicated it will take
time to find
definitive answers the team of experts
from around the world will work with
chinese scientists in wuhan
but first they'll be 14 days of
quarantine
katrina u al jazeera beijing